at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking at the skeleton this episode of
the Tim Ferris Show is brought to you by
99designs an ex-officio 99designs is the
world's largest online marketplace of
graphic designers and I have used 99
designs for years including to get cover
concepts for the 4-hour body which went
on to become number one New York Times
number-one Wall Street Journal it was a
huge hit and here's how it works
and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions you
can see these book covers and so on at
99designs com forward slash Tim whether
you need a logo a car app a web design
an app a thumbnail a t-shirt whatever
you go to 99 designs calm you describe
your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around
the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas and designs
and drafts you have an original design
that you love or you pay nothing it is
fantastic I have used it I have
mentioned it before including in the
4-hour workweek as a resource check it
out 99designs comm forward slash Tim and
if you use that link you'll be able to
see what I've done on the platform you
will also get $99 as an upgrade for free
which will get you more designs more
submissions so check it out ex-officio
boy where do I begin I have a long
history with ex-officio ex-officio makes
clothing and as far back as 2007 2008 I
had a hit video that went viral called
how to travel the world with 10 pounds
or less and I talked about ex-officio
underwear ex-officio underwear is
lightweight ultra lightweight quick
drying and antimicrobial why is this
important well I've gone through 20 plus
countries with two pairs of underwear
before both from ex-officio and I'm not
alone in this this might sound crazy but
a lot of executives for instance will
take this underwear they'll wash it in
the sink or somewhere else roll it up in
towel like a burrito step on it and a
few hours later they are completely dry
completely clean you don't have to just
have to and yes they have to be
comfortable for all-day wear but check
out their clothing as well as their
underwear you can go to ex-officio comm
forward slash Tim that's X DX o FF I
cio.com forward slash Tim and you can
see this video which has a bunch of
other packing tips but this underwear
this clothing is not just for the gents
ladies you have choices too and they
really have an incredible collection of
high quality products that I've used for
almost 10 years now so check them out
ex-officio comm forward slash Tim Wacka
Wacka Wacka boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to the Tim Ferriss show
for those of you new to the program this
is the forum through which I try to
dissect excellence to find the tools and
tactics or approaches that you can use
and that ranges from billionaire
investors to chess prodigies to mega
platinum musicians to in this episode's
case comedian a comedienne en NE a N or
stand-up comic depending on the
terminology the Margaret Cho she has an
illustrious career and is a prodigious
talent and she is also a polymath she's
not only a very celebrated stand-up
comic but she's been a fashion designer
singer-songwriter she's been in feature
films of course and TV series including
sex in the city and 30 rock she's been
on Dancing with the Stars and we don't
have time to go through all of her
accolades but this particular
conversation digs into her inspirations
tricks of the trade different practices
that you can borrow sexuality including
bisexuality and her topics of choice her
different challenges addiction and we
also delve deep into the slow carb diet
so I hope you can indulge me on that
particular segment of the program but it
goes into some nitty gritty details
because Margaret had a bunch of
questions she's followed it and is a fan
of the protocol
so perhaps it'll help some of you out
there and as always you can find the
show notes at 4 hour work week comm
forward slash podcast for links and
further resources for our work week
comport slash podcast and we're using
new audio equipment in this introduction
so let me know what you think be very
curious to hear your thoughts without
further ado please meet Margaret Cho
hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show I am very
excited for this episode because I have
someone that I have admired for a very
long time been a fan of for a very long
time joining us today and that is
Margaret Cho bargain how are you I'm
doing great thank you very much that's
wonderful of course I was I was having
one of my many nights of insomnia which
I've dealt with and improved on and I
was sort of scanning through Twitter and
I came across your profile because I'm a
huge comedy fan and I saw also follows
you and my eyes just about popped out of
my head I was I was so taken aback and
reached out and we connected and and
here we are and here we are but where
where are we finding you at the moment I
know you travel a lot and today I am in
West Palm Beach Florida there is a
something a big storm outside
so that's thunder but I'm always on the
road so that's I'm doing a show here
today it's very cool and I know we have
some precious time with you before you
take off it is hard for me to know even
where to begin because you've done so
many different things and it seems like
lived so many different lives you've had
television books film obviously the the
standup
when you meet someone who's unfamiliar
with your work doesn't recognize you if
they ask you what do you do how do you
even respond to that well yes I think I
identify mostly as a stand-up comedian
and thank you for your kind words I was
excited to connect with you too as I'm a
big fan and I think but comedy is really
what I would say I do I think probably
you're the same and that you are quite a
multi-hyphenate in the different things
you write about and the different things
you talk about and so how would you
define yourself besides you could just
be author or would it be shell or body
expert or thinking expert or multi -
it's are kind of tricky because it's you
know so as you are an author I guess I
am a stand-up comedian you know that's
the basic placer to start from but
there's so much more know for sure it's
it's something that I've I've had
trouble with for a very long time
depending on who I'm talking to and how
badly I want to kill the conversation if
I think they're just being polite and
trying to get through the three or four
cocktail questions so they can glance
over my shoulder and move on I'll say
something like in a professional
dilettante comes to mind drug dealer was
one I used to use and turns out it's a
great way to get people out of your
house at a dinner party if you would ask
them if they want to do heroin or you
know they're there a lot of certain
tricks of the trade
depending on where you are now the the
the the stand-up comedy side of things
i I've had the good fortune of
occasionally having the chance to chat
with people when I've gone to live shows
for instance and I'm always interested
to know and if if you've been asked this
question a thousand times feel free to
answer a different question but what
compels you to do comedy and is it the
same now as it was in the beginning it's
exactly the same the what compels me is
I need to be heard and I need to make
people laugh and I need to express what
I think things that need but he said and
also to to just have a good time you
know and and I've had that impulse I
think since I was about eight years old
I I've always wanted to be a comedian
and you know it's the impulse to do with
this
you know intention everything is the
same there's nothing has altered and I
think this is this is probably the same
for most comedian out there there are
quite a lot of people who do develop a
kind of aversion to it after doing it
for say 30 40 years they'd really feel
like they need to retire but I'm more on
the side of I think I need to do it more
actually as I get older so I'm fortunate
in that it sustains me that it's well
the way that I make a living but it's
also my social life and and a great
pastime and a great great great thing to
do
that the the aspect of my career that a
lot of people ask about is writing and
I've noticed they're different breeds of
writers this is this is going to come
back to the stand-up question what a lot
of writers and I would say myself
included have a come of a a need almost
a therapeutic need to write at points no
matter how hard the process is almost as
a way of of self-medicating and getting
neuroses out of their heads and I'm not
projecting here but this is this is for
me there there are many times when I
will I will write in the morning the
material I know is pure garbage it's
just completely self-indulgent morning
pages but it's it's my equivalent of
taking my psyche and sort of whacking
the rug to get the dust out of it before
I move on to my day so that I don't have
all the grow the gremlins in my head and
I'm curious if at least in the stand-up
world or the comedy world it seems it
seems that that people have different
drives and different things that keep
them going and I'd be curious to know if
you could comment on what it is for you
well I think that I have the equivalent
of the morning pages sort of thing
because I work almost every day I mean I
perform almost every day there there are
different things that I do but in sanik
comic it is really a daily effort and so
you know you kind of burn off all of
those kind of like ideas
like lately floating on the top and then
you can get to the real need of it so I
guess I have that kind of a meditation
too I wish that I had more of that as a
writer you know as an author for me you
know that's something that I would like
to pursue more but I still don't have
the intense need for it that I do as a
stand-up comedian when did you do your
first professional stand-up and when did
you decide that you were going to do it
professionally
oh I decided that I was going to do
professionally when I understood that I
was going to become an adult in that one
at some point you know this would be my
job and and and then my identity as soon
as I understood what the job of fan of
comedy was then I became very committed
to doing it and that's I think an
unusual thing maybe for somebody to
choose a profession at 8 years old but I
knew that it was actually more than a
profession it was really a kind of a
calling and then I really started early
I started doing professional
performances at 14 I was touring by 15 I
was making pretty great living by 18 and
then I was on television about 20 so it
was a it was a very very important thing
for me and it was really death to me who
were some of those the early
inspirations and role models for you
that that you look to as models if that
were the case at all and then the very
early days the main model for my earlier
and then of course pretty much until now
was Joan Rivers and that that's been a
very difficult you know right now a lot
of comedians are feeling the loss of
both her and robin williams and then
it's h a really it's a terrible time in
comedy because it's like we lost our the
king and queen you know now it's like
who is the heir apparent but mostly
it's the sorrow and mourning so it'sit's
pretty terrible and what made what made
Joan special obviously she had just an
incredible career in longevity in
endurance I mean my god but what what
was it that of all of the people out
there really appealed to you about her
when you were getting started I think
that she was so unafraid
she was so mr. fearlessness and she was
a woman and she was just so mighty um
and you know as a live comic you know
like the stuff that she would do in
clubs and at night like not you know not
including like the any close red carpet
stuff or the Oscar stuff she was so
filthy I mean she was so I mean to the
very end
you know just the most raunchy comedian
you could even imagine and she was
shocked us you know the most unshockable
people it was incredible and and also
the reason why she and I were close is
that she really taught me a lot about
gratitude you know she had intense and
immense gratitude for everything in her
life and wanted me and all these other
comedians that she would foster in a way
that they she wanted to instill that
enough that that this was a really
magical thing this gift that we were
given and that we should be really
grateful for it and and that's the most
valuable lesson I've ever learned from
anyone so she was really a combination
parent like a mother and whatever like
mr. Miyagi like Pat Morita from Karate
Kid like she was a really she was a
great mentor and a great woman do you
have any particular ways in which you
practice gratitude is that part of your
schedule in some way or is that just a
philosophy yeah so I should I mean it
would be really great to have that as a
practice to make a gratitude list or
something like that but mostly it's just
an attitude every day like I'm really
happy and what I do I really love what I
do it's a really great feeling to do
what you love and you know for me it's
about making money of course but that I
would still do stand-up comedy without
making anything I put just as much
effort into every show no matter how
much I'm making or whatever it's
something that I always wanted and I'm
so happy that I get to do it and I think
that it's just wonderful so I don't
actually have a practice but it might be
something nice to implement later if
we're looking at your your schedule or
your rituals actually before we even get
to that you mentioned fearlessness and
there are very few things I can imagine
that would strike complete panic into my
heart more than getting up on stage and
doing stand-up where you really have to
you really are not going to be given any
mercy laughs by most people I mean you
have to stand on your own merit what
what are some of the when of you what
what are some instances where you have
been most afraid on stage where I lost
my voice and then I had to figure out
how to do shows without having a voice
so I used a like some voice software and
my computer and then I also brought
people on to some stage you would ask
things out somewhere I would actually
ask them out and they would read them
from behind so it was like a puppet or
something so that was helpful but it was
really terrifying to not have the
capacity to deal with a heckler which
I'm very good at it's one of my
specialities you know it's like you know
kind of the immediacy of live
performance you know I took away my
spontaneity it took away just a lot of
the kind of freshness and the the
unpredictability of what live
performance in stand-up comedy is which
to me is the greatest part of it so that
was really terrible
and then I've you know that bad show I
mean I probably have the worst shows of
anybody in my category you know and in
the level that I am as a comedian
because I'm so committed to taking risks
as a performer I can really do terribly
and sometimes that can be really scary
if you're say in different countries
like in England or Scotland where it
it's like there's a high anger high
security people don't see well in Albany
and you know that I got really bad
fights and you know a couple of
instances where I was really scared for
a physical horn because I really was not
I give it to people I merely let them
have it if I'm backed into a corner and
so it can be it can be really nice if
you can get really angry when you said
and I'm just paraphrasing here but I'd
love for you to expand a bit hon on what
you what you just mentioned related to
sort of having the potential to do worst
in your category or class of comic why
do you have sort of higher crash and
burn potential or what's what's the why
do you have the added risk factor I
think because I will come off of
anything scripted and I will go with the
flow and then I will really engage with
an audience in a very personal level
like I'm not the kind of artist that can
go on autopilot which actually happens
much more than people realize right like
I don't have I don't really have that
ability so I build it from the ground up
and I build it from scratch every time
from from the beginning and so that in
itself it's a huge risk when you're not
necessarily relying on the
tried-and-true and things that you know
work and you're going into everything
would it tabula rasa that it you you
really are
you're plugging into something divine
but that divinity is not all super
locket bubble is where you meant so it
can be really just very scary and I
think that that's the energy that I
strive off of that's what I love but
that innately is kind of a risky
behavior sure right yeah you can be
knocking for the muse and they might not
be open for business that particular
talking about hecklers so this this I
would love to dig into a little bit what
are your favorite ways of dealing with
hecklers I mean is there a sort of a you
know Margaret Cho playbook do you have
any any particular responses if you're
just like you know what I don't want to
deal with this guy right now I need to
cut them off at the knees what are some
of the fastest ways of dealing with with
hecklers and you know maybe there are
different types of hecklers I'm sure
there are but I'd love to hear a little
bit about that well there's different
types but the best thing to do is to
really just out now engage somebody and
really try to find out what they're
trying to say and and so there's no set
like plant there's no set lines or the
descripted idea of what to say to shut
them down it's really going deeper and
finding out why this person was choosing
to disrupt a performance that everybody
has paid for that everybody is there and
agreed to sit for why did somebody want
a rebelled against that and so I you
know I'm curious about it and I'll
usually give them quite a lot of time
like if I have there's because there's a
potential to create a whole show around
them and then I learn from oh it's great
I learned from Paula Poundstone who's an
absolute genius at that I mean she will
she'll do a show and if somebody gets up
to go to the bathroom she'll go to their
chair so go to their chair and she'll
take your jacket and put it on and go
through their pocket and really just I
mean she is so fearless when it comes to
talking to an audience and so I learned
that from her I mean
doesn't have to detract from your
performance it can really be an
incredible journey that will only be
taking one time and you know it's not to
encourage acting it shows but sometimes
it's really inevitable so my my goal is
to just try to take that road as it
presents itself if it doesn't work it
but usually if the only reason it
doesn't work is if the person is too
drunk yeah how this happens kicked out
now if they're if they're not
excessively drunk what type of question
might you ask them or questions if
there's like you know you can tell
they're not totally drunk there's being
an idiot
what what type of what type of question
might you ask them or what might you say
to them well you know why they're
yelling out or what the what the purpose
is of what they need you know and then I
can ask them like about who they're with
I can ask the person they're with about
why they're saying that like why are
they like that or they like this all the
time there's a special thing and I'll
get an explanation from the partner or
whatever interesting you don't then you
can also talk to other people around
them like people that are seated next to
them like what was it person like before
the show what were they say and what you
know like what led us to this and then
somebody from another part of the room
will complain about it and then you go
over there and do the same thing but it
can be very very interesting if you just
utilize what they're saying and you you
incorporate it into what you're doing
and then if you have an excitement in
cyclope dick knowledge of your jokes and
therefore you know you can call on
anything that you might have that would
be would be relevant but I love that
immediacy I think it is really what it's
great about stand-up comedy is that
there's that potential to do anything oh
sure yeah no absolutely I mean that's
that's part of part of why I enjoy going
to live shows you really don't know how
the movies gonna end I mean you don't
you have no idea of how things are going
to develop let's see here are there any
particular I'm just trying to think here
non stand-up influences so people who
are not stand-up comics who have
affected and those this could be movies
books anything or people but outside of
the realm of comedy who have impacted
how you perform how you present how you
develop your material well I think um
Madonna is great I love Chrissie Hynde I
love a lot of like female rock singers
like they I am a musician also so we get
a lot of inspiration from Bjork
again you know like this music is always
really inspiring and and you know just
like the performance style of somebody
like Janis Joplin I would love to
capture as a comedian that would be my
ideal if I could be comedian edit that
is the motive Janis Joplin as a singer
that would be great
so singers are incredibly influential
and I think it's because a long long
long time ago I I happened upon a pet
psychic who though is it I had a dog who
a it loves very much and you know it was
she it was like this television show
about pet psychics oh I was doing it I I
was talking to her and she said that my
dog thought that I was a singer because
dogs don't understand what stand-up
comedy is so I thought that was the
sweetest of what I do he thought I was
singing you know prohibited itself you
know that's that's really what type of
dog he was he died but he was a big
shivered mix like a big like fluffy guy
that he would get at the pound
it was kind of every dog at one but he
was it that I it makes me think of very
very early on for me when my first book
had just come out in 2007 I was headed
to South by Southwest for the first time
to give my first real keynote and I was
extremely nervous I was just a sweaty
nervous mess even days beforehand and I
had no real way to rehearse in front of
people so I ended up going to my
friend's garage he had three Chihuahuas
of different sizes and I realized that
if I focused on presenting to them that
I assumed they didn't understand a word
but if my actual style of presentation
is not really dynamic they would get
bored and walk away but if if I was if I
was really animated they would sit there
kind of bug-eyed and look at me so I
used the chihuahuas as my test audience
for for developing my material for that
first yeah yeah and it was it actually
worked out extremely well because my my
tech failed my laptop had some type of
glitch in the the projector wasn't
working so I had to go off I had to go
off-script and I had to to work without
the tech the the the question of
fearlessness and being nervous onstage
you you are not shy at least as people
know you now about talking about it race
gender sexuality you really cross into
all sorts of different worlds that that
many people I assume would avoid because
they're they're perceived as sensitive
topics were you ever nervous about
broaching those types of subjects early
on or have you for very GetGo no it's a
nerve-racking thing because you know you
want to have a semblance of privacy and
then sometimes when you reveal things on
stage that you know are pretty that can
it can be kind of weird and you know
like I I think that but I think the
privacy is really overrated though
because it's just a kind of a social
construct that doesn't really mean that
much because all human beings are we
felt all the same things we've had all
the same heartbreaks and tragedies and
dumb things and stupid things and you
know we really are not know none of us
is a stranger to that if you've lived it
all you know so you know it's not like
anything I say it's not like something
we haven't everybody has it felt but
still things can feel odd and weird but
so I was more cautious of it when I was
younger that like I'm bisexual and I was
really scared of revealing that for
maybe the first 10 years of my career
because I was told by my management then
that it would be really bad to be gay in
any way and that I should not express
and so that was really scary thing
because you know in relationships with
women and and self and III I had to hide
that which I always felt odd and weird
that I could have fine relationships
with men and show that but with women
who would somehow wrong and and so I I
really gave up trying to pretend that I
was anything but myself very early when
did you when did you make that leap what
was the the year roughly I'm just trying
to think of it in terms of the kind of
cultural and political climate when did
you come out so to speak publicly I
think probably about 95 and I'm six
something like yeah pretty early on but
then women are now I realized and I look
back on you know women to women sexual
womens bisexuality is a lot more I don't
know it's a lot more easy to deal with
or people have a harder time dealing
with men and male sexuality and fluidity
there but what's hard is women who are
just them like to justify enough
lesbians I think they have a hard time
as opposed to women or bisexual there's
a there's some there's some kind of
glamour and Majesty attached to bisexual
women I'm not sure is true but it's
certainly just there's a kind of an
archetype or stereotype even oh sure I
mean I think that you know even in I
live in San Francisco I've been there
for ages and it's sort of joked that you
know bisexual women no matter what which
is ridiculous of course but or you know
often referred to as unicorns and you
know I think there's that there's that
it sort of holds occupies a very unique
place in the mind space of even
mainstream America for whatever reason
but yeah what have you ever
have you ever had disclosed anything on
stage that at least for a period of time
you regretted well I think I earlier I'm
working on the show that's really about
a mental illness and addiction which is
part of the sort of trajectory of the
thing that I'm trying to explain and so
I'm talking a lot about prescription
pill addiction which I had a really bad
case in it for and stopped about a year
ago but before that it had been about
five years where I was really having a
problem but you know it's like one of
those things where you know that
addiction is really strange because it's
so deadly and destructive just in the
way that a heroin addiction would be but
you know it's prescribed by a doctor and
I was actually getting it from my actual
doctor and it was that you know that
there was all of these levels of
legitimacy to it that and then secrecy
as well and so disclosing that is very
it's very weird because you know it
really shatters a lot of these illusions
of I don't know a maturity and you know
being sane like sanity and stuff so you
know that's a whole another thing like
it's hard to disclose but it's also
important to because that honesty keeps
me not sober because I I still drink red
wine but I think it keeps me sort of
more sane than I would because that's a
really crazy addiction to have yeah I
think it's a very insidious like you
mentioned also because it's extremely
common even when doctors themselves
extremely common yeah but it's not
talked about nearly as much in detail as
you pointed out for instance compared to
heroin addiction or something like that
what type of what type of medications
just out of curiosity Oh everything like
percocet you know you can get oh you
know like you could get oh this is weird
but you
what lean is or suzer which is like
hydrocodone cough syrup yes that or even
to morphine or methadone or anything
kind of owe any opiates like that this
that that was really my problem and it
was really really destructive but at the
same time you don't exactly feel high so
it's almost a cheat like you're actually
not really high
you're just not sick after you can
properly addicted to those drugs they
really are no they have no use at all
right as I kind of a high they really
only serve to keep you from being sick
that thing yeah just you needed to get
to baseline to not have the physical
withdrawal symptoms speaking personally
I think I've been very fortunate in a
lot of respects of course but one is
that hydrocodone vicodin etc all make me
extremely nauseous oh so all of these
opioid derivative drugs make me very
very sick and learn that after shoulder
surgery I was given all these
painkillers and I couldn't really take
any of them because they made me so sick
which i think is is a blessing in
disguise in a lot of ways because my
likelihood of abusing those things is
very very low do you find at least
within the world of comedy that people
tend to if they have addictive
personalities and I have no idea if
addiction is is more or less common in
in stand-up comics than the general
population of course a lot of the
tragedies are highlighted which I think
might might skew the public perception
but do people tend to be either addicted
to sort of depressants and opiates or
stimulants I mean do people often end up
addicted to both or do they tend to fall
on one side or the other they can just
fall on one side or the other I mean I I
myself can say I'm much more of a
depressant I'm much more like a downer
right but I've never been at cocaine or
whatever you know that's never been my
things but then there's people who are
just want everything and then stand-up
comics in particular like our job is
really to obsess on things that's what
stand-up comedy is just obsessing over a
topic where you're just going crazy on
something and you know that's fine in
the context of stand-up comedy but it's
terrible if you're just living in the
world and so you know the the the
connection with comedy comics being
depressed and self-destructive and
suicidal it goes with the territory
because the job that you need it
requires that kind of thinking so it can
be pretty difficult to manage it and
then if you add drugs on top of that it
can be really really hard and in the
lifestyle also because it's very
solitary when you're traveling all the
time you're on sweep schedule is off
it's weird it's a jetlag and then also
press and shows so it's a very it's a
destructive and very difficult lifestyle
almost like being in a band but you
you're not with anybody else you're the
only one so you know as musicians are
very legendarily known to be very
self-destructive in the same way at
least they have a community with them on
tour even if it's just a few guys on a
on a you know van you know so we don't
have that as comics were just alone and
it could be really messy definitely and
I think that perhaps to a lesser degree
you see you see some very similar
symptoms of problems surfacing in a lot
of writers as well particularly writers
who develop a habit of number one
they're going to be isolated almost by
definition and that's part of the reason
that I'm taking a break from writing
books quite frankly is because three
three years at a stress at three years
at a stretch inside your own head is
sometimes a scary place to be and why
particularly those writers who develop a
late night writing schedule which is
something that I have I think run to
bouts of depression and darkness and I
mean of course there's a sort of long
history of people like Hemingway who end
up not at a very
positive punch line you know at the end
of things yeah personality-wise do you
find that there are certain
characteristics that are common among
the people in the people the stand-up
comics who are addicted to stimulants
versus depressants I mean do you find
that there's you could you can kind of
guess which people are going to go one
way or the other
yeah I think people who are really a DD
you know we're really kind of
scatterbrains and they're they're
they're reminder everywhere I think that
just like hyperactive kids are given
ritalin and adderal I think they're
really helped or they they tend to crave
stimulants because it focuses them right
and and then I think that people who are
pretty focused but depressed and kind of
mu D minor chord like down down were
gazing bummed out
people are really helped and listed by
opiates because they offer this
injections of diseases of endorphins
which is something that they're either
lacking like your serotonin is messed up
or whatever they're just not getting it
and then the positivity that for the
bursts of positivity that opiate can
give you the courses food is countered
by terrible depression which is actually
worse than your baseline makes
everything way WAY worse you know that I
can see why that that would be
attractive I mean that's what I have you
know I find I have that kind of a
downward sort of thing I take some
effort to look for positivity and also
for gratitude which is ones are grateful
for like my own gratitude and why I need
it so much for sure how did you how did
you just what was the catalyzing moment
that led you to start taking your
prescription drug addiction seriously
how did and then headed how did you end
up kicking it what was what did that
look like well I guess really uh I I
just really had no idea how much I was
taking I really had no idea
what I was taking I didn't understand
that contraindications I could have
caught a complete like crazy um you know
finger things are loves doing like to
myself and then I was taking like all
the ambien which is another thing which
I think is actually very very dangerous
drug that people many many people are
very dependent on but I also have a very
it's a bit I have a bad insomnia problem
and so but that in combination with
opiates is the deadly thing you know my
friend Anna Nicole Smith died from that
and really it was that kind of suicidal
behavior of taking so much pills and not
knowing if I would wake up and not
really thinking I would wake up I think
that that was really it just became
really apparent so I just kind of threw
everything away and then you know I told
everybody in my around me my circle and
I you know my work and you know I was
talking about it on stage and I made it
very clear that this is a problem that I
was going through and I think just
making that making it not a secret
anymore was real is what it was all
about when I wasn't having to hide sick
or talk talk you know if I talked about
it then it really resolved the situation
I fortunately was able to just walk away
and I I was very sick for a time because
the natural you know that's what happens
when you take the Turks but afterwards I
was much better and I didn't have a kind
of a need to go fast to it or a sense
that this this was going to be repeated
so you know it it wasn't like I went to
rehab and it wasn't like I sought
treatment which most people should but I
just was able to escape
fortunately how did that the day that
you throughout all of your medication
why that day was there did you scare
yourself somehow was there a
conversation did you look in the mirror
and see something you hadn't noticed
before what why that day I just think
there will
so many patches in my memory that I
didn't understand why I didn't remember
and I didn't understand like I could
feel the whatever that the generation of
my brain I could really feel it
- ability sense that did I don't think
I'm gonna get that part of my brain back
like I really felt an emptiness I got
cleared out like I had deleted files
that I didn't want to delete and that
was so terrible you know when you just
have like a blank space when you should
have something there and evidence that
things that were not going wrong like
room service I don't know that I ordered
and you know like weird photos on my
phone that I don't know who these people
are and why I have them right and weird
sexual situations that were like I
should not like Who am I talking to in
this manner that I don't remember even
meeting like what what is going on like
that all these things at once right and
you go I have to get out of this like
this is really a weird space because
it's almost like somebody takes over
your body for you he drives it yeah and
that's really strange
no I agreed and I've seen just speaking
of ambien been on trips before with
friends where I've seen them come
downstairs after going to sleep like The
Walking Dead on ambien go crazy doing
all sorts of ridiculous things for hours
go back to their bed and have no
recollection of any of it the next day
one of my two best friends growing up
about I'd say a year and a half ago died
of an accidental contraindication he was
he had a lot of alcohol never to me
never took any illicit drugs or
recreational drugs and he was
complaining to a buddy of his about a
headache and his buddy gave him a very
strong prescription depressant and he
took it never woke up that was it it
just took one shot so yeah people need
to take the alcohol interactions really
seriously and oh yeah that's
to me that's a major major problem with
alcohol and ambien and also opiates - I
mean the whole thing Rex your liver but
on top of that it's a judgment that goes
completely out the window like you don't
know what you're doing it there's
something that alcohol does in that it
just really messes everything up yeah
for sure
well you I think it's just a very
important sort of topic to explore for
folks but to switch gears a little bit
because I'm I'm constantly impressed
with just how prolific you are and have
been what is what does your process look
like for developing material so let's
just say that you've just finished I
you've just finished a special or you
just finished
you basically aced whatever you've been
working on for the last X period of time
and it's time to it's time for you to
start over you have that feeling what
does the process look like how do you
come up with your material well usually
I will probably involve a trip to San
Francisco actually where I get started
it recently you know came back to the
city yeah and I hung out with old
comedian friends you know I haven't seen
for a while and you know there's a lot
of little shows that happen there's like
the deluxe on Haight Street and then
there's like um you know a bunch of
different kinds of nights that happen
usually something like Sunday to
Wednesday which is for comedians are
days off and so that's when I'll start
to go to these like little kind of clubs
in the city and work things out so I
like kind of put together just
everything new you know just out of
notes that I have and I'll do that and
they'll do that in different cities and
a mental work them into my larger
performances where I will have some like
level of prepared material but then I'll
also work on the new script from you
think and also improvise where I am and
it just grows you know but usually it's
built from a small you know maybe two or
three jerks and it'll grow into
an hour of comedy that would be ready
would take about it we need a here to
make it really perfect because I would
take it internationally and make sure
that it is great and then I'll actually
commit it to either a special or album
or something like that did you take it
international before you test it on the
main stage in the US is the do you use
international as well so that's really
interesting I that's the first I've
heard of that and you know a lot of
folks may not realize that even
companies like Nike for instance will do
tons of testing in places like New
Zealand smaller english-speaking
countries to refine the products and
marketing and positioning and everything
that they then bring back to the US but
they don't want to have their debutante
ball in the in the major leagues that's
really interesting yeah it's great
because what's great about going
internationally is part of the the joy
of performing there in the audience is
just so grateful that you came but they
will give you some skin cut you some
slack you so much it's a great thing
because you can actually work negotiate
a kind of a like a nice workshop with
them because they they're they they know
how far away it is they know you don't
have to turn there but they know you
from whatever a different thing than
they so glad that you're there so for me
it's a great great thing and it's not
something that a lot of comedians in the
mirror could do so I for some reason
have the ability to travel and I get to
do many many countries in Europe except
the only countries I haven't done shows
in are like Italy and Spain which it
just gives the market that's very
different there but every place else has
been really fantastic and and Australia
also I had to cancel a New Zealand tour
because I've got a was doing like a TV
show but I definitely look forward to
going back there but international
markets are really wonderful for me to
about what I want to do in the future
what what make Spain and Italy so
different I'm very curious I think
because of the Catholicism it's
difficult for women to talk about sex in
the way that I do
right you know I'm very very like this
is a joke that I'm telling you I don't
even know if I should tell this joke but
I just I haven't had sex in a very long
time not a really long time but I was
upset because Robin Williams died and
Joan Riverside my cat I couldn't I don't
want to you know and I just didn't feel
like and so I was out to dinner in San
Francisco not long ago and I was with
two gay guys which is my wedding I love
gay men with these guys I love we're at
the House of prime rib which is
excellent Oh fantastic yeah and exactly
what is good it's really good and we're
eating and then the sommelier is so cute
you know I'm talking to him and then I
thought he was so adorable and then he's
really young too and we left and then my
friends are like well you know they're
trying to encourage me like you should
talk to one connealy like you I was like
oh he's too young and I don't want to
make one of them went back and gave the
guy my phone number
and I was like whatever and then so
anyway went back to my hotel and I was
like one of the morning and the guy
actually called me which is amazing I
thought it was so brave so he came over
and it was wonderful it was like it was
like a therapy dog I don't think you can
tell that to joke and it's not a joke
it's two stories but I don't think you
can tell that champion Italy I can tell
that joke in Spain without some kind of
repercussions of people getting really
angry like what are your doing like how
can you just do that you know I'm I'm 45
year old woman I I I'm really you know I
feel right to me that he was much
younger than me I feel he should have
had sex with his father this was not
right but it was really what I needed
you know I I wonder about that I mean
given given the intensity of porn that
comes out of Italy not that I would know
anything about that but just I'm
astonished that they would be so
judgmental to people on the stage but I
guess there's the the public facing
laughing and then there's the private
porn viewing and maybe those are two
different mentalities
go figure
and also you know because of the
language do and also I'm just just I
think it's hard for American comments
just in general but especially somebody
that's really brash and talking about
sexuality and and how it isn't a
shameful thing it's kind of it's a
little bit much you know for that so
those markets have always been a little
bit what which markets on the flip side
which countries respond best to the
brash sex talk and everything else
um Sweden France is incredible Germany
it's probably the best but Finland
definitely Norway is amazing all of
Scandinavia is so down with it you know
they're so excited just Denmark is
incredible
I think they traditionally been very
very sex positive we know that their
their history and corn is pretty amazing
so that's a great place to go to but um
a lot of a lot like you know kind of
sort of northern kind of colder
countries but I think in Germany
medieval the ultimate place because
there's so much liberal thought there so
much a kind of ease about sexuality
there that is really amazing yeah I'm
glad you mentioned Denmark those are my
people that's that's probably yeah half
my bloodline big of it that's why I have
that my big blockage sort of Lego head
is courtesy of my Danish genetics I
didn't get the height though that's kind
of a ripoff I got the you know I got the
the gigantic head the sort of sponge
pants squarebob or whatever his name had
but without without the height so it
goes when just to get to jump to a
different type of question when you
think of the word successful who's the
first person who comes to mind and why
oh well I guess it would be Steve Jobs
that that would be that you know
somebody was so successful beyond and
and also visionary that you could became
kind of a legendary
mm that was like beyond human so I think
that would be my definition of success
is somebody that sort of like crosses a
line from like business to art to I
don't even know what that is you know
that kind of visionary it's pretty
profound do you do you feel successful I
think a lot of people would consider you
successful do you feel because it's
successful yourself oh absolutely I know
that I am you know I'm very grateful for
that and I know that that an achievement
that there's much much higher levels of
success I would like to achieve but then
you know I no slouch especially because
I'm probably and my peers the one who
sustained it the longest you know that
that I have been pretty active and out
there you know very very visibly for the
last 20 years and so that's the good
thing yeah it's hard to make it's hard
to string it together for that long for
sure if if you could change or improve
one thing about yourself what would that
be I would like to have a lower
percentage of body fat which is why I'm
doing for our awesome well you know you
mentioned before we started recording
that you had some some some food
questions I'm happy to answer those
obviously about your I almost dread mine
because I am physically sick every time
I over said I've been eating now and for
our body for very religiously now for
about maybe several months at four or
five months and it's a big difference
but I try to go for the three day the
cheat day and I dread it like I'm afraid
of it doesn't feel good to me because
it's any kind of flower or acceptive
amounts of sugar or anything they taste
so good but they don't feel good in my
body and I wonder if there's a way to
manage I have a better suggestion during
that time it's a different doesn't feel
good to me
sure no I can comment on that the so the
cheat day is designed to do a few things
but the first is based on the assumption
that people are going to cheat no matter
what and you can contain the damage if
you schedule it in advance so that's
sort of principle number one principle
number two is that by spiking caloric
intake once a week you can help to
prevent a lot of kind of downgrading of
the metabolism whether that's thyroid or
otherwise there or there are people out
there who say for instance well I'm only
gonna have one cheat meal instead of a
cheat day to limit the damage that I do
I only recommend that to people if that
means they won't succumb to cravings
later in the week so by being disgusted
once a week it's not mandatory but
typically what happens is exactly what
you're describing so people start to
dread overdoing it on cheat day and they
naturally start to dial it back a little
bit and in the beginning when people are
most likely to quit any diet in the
first two to three weeks that cheat day
is so overdone they're just just so
disgusted that then that evening and the
following day they can't wait to get
back to a cleaner type of eating because
they just feel better there are ways to
cheat so to speak to spike the caloric
intake without having some of the
digestive issues if that is a problem
for a lot of people for a lot of people
that means simply avoiding gluten among
other things so for instance if I am
training for athletics or I know that I
have to have a lot of work done on a
bottom Sunday or a Monday just the day
after a cheat day I will focus on say
carbs or carb rich foods like sweet
potatoes or brown rice or even white
rice as opposed to getting it from wheat
flour things of that type that are I
know going to just put up put up a huge
fight going through my digestive tract
so there are they're definitely wasted
and minimize some of the discomfort
while still checking the boxes that
prevent you from cheating later another
another recommendation is that you can
make the first meal of the day a slow
carb compliant meal and a very easy way
to do that is to just this for instance
you could have a a small amount of
lentils out of a can I mean literally
this is something I'll do often times
that we'll have and there there are a
lot of reasons for this but the fiber
and which is important for kind of gut
flora and bacterial balance in the GI
tract you could have just spoon out of a
can literally lentils in the morning
with maybe one or two eggs and that will
that will naturally inhibit your
appetite later in the day so you'll be
able to cheat but you'll be less prone
to put unit to ingesting the last 2,000
calories of you know rocky road ice
cream with Snickers on top or whatever
yeah because it's usually I think for a
lot of people they do cheat day they get
to a point where they're like holy [ __ ]
I am about to explode and they look at
the clock and they're like but it's ten
o'clock I have two more hours to go
I can't let cheat day end without giving
it one last hurrah and it's just it's
it's that last extra serving or that
last Guinness or whatever that just
takes them from about to explode to just
complete insulin coma yeah so the the
the the slow carb compliant meal early
in the day can help the grapefruit juice
plus caffeine early in the day because
of the nur in Jenin and all of that can
also help because it will stabilize
somewhat your blood sugar and your
insulin response so those are those are
a few recommendations there are lots of
ways to customize cheat day but the most
important I think the most important
thing to realize about cheat day is that
you should not you should not feel like
you are restricting yourself on schita
that's the most important thing so some
people will try to do a healthy cheat
day but then
they have a to eat list of all these
things that they don't want to give up
and they end up cheating on a Wednesday
night or a Thursday night and like most
people who do that they say I [ __ ] air
it had one cookie I'm gonna have now I'm
gonna have the rest of all these Girl
Scout cookies because I already [ __ ]
up and then they then they backslide and
they don't stick with it so as long as
you know as long as you don't feel like
you are you have secret cravings that
you're not satisfying during Cheeta you
can pretty much do whatever you want
well what's interesting about the diet
or just the way it is in my body is that
I don't have any crazy but I just don't
I don't actually care
I do the cheat day because it's tastes
good but it's not because I had a
craving you know is that I just I do it
because it's gonna help my help my
overall process which is I think I think
that's what's the best thing about it
for me is that it I don't have that need
for pasta or bread that I did before
although it still tastes really good
when I have it that's just the needs
word I you know the things that you
think you can't do much before you
started and then you started and your
idea about food changes yeah yeah
definitely and and it's it's very much a
combination of biochemistry and
psychology right I mean you have a
certain shift where I think the the
biochemical changes and the
physiological changes precede the
psychological realization that you don't
need certain things so you have a
certain chemical dependency just like
getting off of prescription medications
you have a certain chemical dependency
which could be related to the types of
refined carbohydrates that people are
accustomed eating for breakfast which
sets the stage for the rest of the day
and makes them fall asleep at 1:30 or
2:00 p.m. but when you start when you
start to add in the protein the fat and
fiber then those type of dramatic
glucose swings start to level out and as
you're sort of like your pancreas
becomes resynthesized or at least you
develop some too
of insulin sensitivity again your body
stops having to work so hard and it
prevents a lot of the rollercoasters and
then like you said about a week into it
two weeks into it you're like wow I
don't crave those foods I thought I
would crave forever and yeah it's it's
it's really fascinating and the the
entire diet is really designed to have
the highest compliance rate possible and
I think this is sometimes lost on say
paleo or vegan purists who want everyone
to convert to a very inconvenient diet
on day one and my point is the the good
program you follow is better than the
perfect program that you quit and the
slow carb diet it is a great gateway
drug in a positive sense for getting
people to eliminate the vast amount of
garbage that they consume so right right
now that's all it's really it's very
helpful I think the strangest thing that
is that I'm really not hungry
because I was like starving all the time
and I'm like why do I I mean obviously
there's reasons why but it's like I
don't have that if I I just don't I'm
never really hungry ever even when I
haven't eaten for several hours and
somehow sustains my system it just
burned yeah and I'm not desperate for
food yeah it's it's a really cool I
think for a lot of people a very cool
realization of self-sufficiency that
that that that people do not experience
hunger in the same way it's it becomes a
very different experience and yet a part
of that is you're using things like
cheat day and you're using in some cases
supplements but not certainly not
necessary at all to change how how your
your your brain and your body
produce and respond to hormones like
gralen and all sorts of other things and
what's what's really cool about it rina
recently I did a I did a 7 day water
fast so I went 7 days with nothing
besides water with no supplementation no
electrolytes
anything and because of these indirect
training of the slow carb diet and
effectively readying my system for that
type of experience it really wasn't
terribly difficult and I'm not
recommending anyone do that without
medical supervision but the the body
becomes a very very resilient and the
the one of the questions that I get
before people start things in this in
the 4-hour body particularly this low
carb diet is what do I eat for snacks
and my my answer is if you're eating
enough and you should be eating enough
at your meals you're not going to be
hungry you don't need and and and
typically what people realize is that
the snacking is a compulsive habitual
behavior it's not because they are
hungry right therefore they're they're
basically eating their pancreas not
their stomach if that makes sense
because their insulin response is so out
of whack and once you fix that it's like
oh I want to have a bowl of
fill-in-the-blank crap next to my
computer because that's my habit but I'm
not actually hungry right and then it
puts into question what is food for
anyway right you know like there there's
a you know it's the cool thing yeah yeah
and in my you know one of the ways to
modify cheat day so that it's it's it's
more rewarding and less disgusting
although I think that that getting
people to the oh my god I'm so disgusted
with myself point is actually very
valuable in the first few weeks yeah but
when you graduate from that you're like
okay I've covered the I'm disgusted with
myself checkbox like I want to be more
functional towards the the latter third
of my cheat day you you can start to set
rules for yourself such as you know the
food the food either has to be really
good for me or it has to be [ __ ]
delicious and the the [ __ ] delicious
part is important because people on
cheat day will often just shovel
whatever shitty food is in front of them
or around them right into their model
it gets real so when you and I would say
you know the in the same way that you're
looking for high quality if you choose
to eat meat and I eat meat that you
choose to try to find high quality meat
right so home it's an in San Francisco
I'm gonna look for grass-fed beef I'm
gonna look for so on and so forth
similarly if you're cheating you can do
the same thing and you can say all right
I'm gonna have pasta but I want pasta
made from fresh ingredients from that
that does so I'm gonna go to you know
flour and water and this is just a
restaurant in San Francisco and I'm
gonna get pasta there or I want ice
cream and I want high quality ice cream
I'm not just going to go to Safeway and
eat five gallons of the cheapest crap I
can find you know I'm going to go to buy
right or whatever and it might be a
little bit more expensive but I'm gonna
get higher quality raw ingredients I'm
gonna have cheat meals but I'm gonna
have fewer preservatives and artificial
sweeteners and all that [ __ ] so there
definitely ways to make your cheat day a
little more regal you know it really is
been it's a real tree and a real luxury
but you know like I've avoided my last
couple of cheat days because it just
really made me second you know the food
program reminds me a bit of when you go
to Overeaters Anonymous there's a very
specific there's two sets kind of sex as
Overeaters Anonymous is one is called
house and one is called the Cambridge
group where it's just a food plan that
you cannot deviate from and you just can
never deviate from but this gay people
want freedom from the addictive
properties of eating and so you know in
a sense it reminds me of that and that
like now that the food is out of the way
the obsessing about food is out of the
way now I can actually like live my life
which i think is really the wonderful
thing no I mean and that makes me I mean
that makes my gay
it makes my week just to hear that it's
it's it's it's a liberating point for
people to reach and what I've found is
that a lot of behavioral a lot of
systems of behavioral change
that have existed for many decades are
completely just scientifically off-base
they haven't really been tested so the
idea that you can take someone who's
accustomed to eating a horrible diet and
put them on a strict vegetarian diet and
they're going to adhere to that it will
have less than ten percent success rate
you can't start there it's very
difficult and if you want if you want
five hundred out of a thousand people to
succeed instead of a hundred out of a
thousand then you provide them with sort
of a graduated approach and I think
there's I think there is an incredible
tactical application of excess right so
people will say well everything in
moderation I'm like actually I don't
think that humans are good at moderation
so that's why it's easier to go a month
without alcohol than having one drink a
day if you're an alcoholic it's I
actually even and I there are there many
examples of this but you know my mom was
cured of smoking at one point because
her her parents and I'm not saying this
is a great in general parenting approach
but they said to all the the siblings
they said Oh found out that one of you
likes to smoke well here's a box of
cigars and you guys can have all of the
cigars and when you're done then you can
come upstairs and man they did not know
anything for a very very very long time
and again not recommending that very old
school but in the psychologically the
cheat day for the first two or three
weeks is achieving something very
similar yeah so I mean I'm thrilled that
that you've been been with it for a few
months obviously I'm always happy to
answer questions I never get tired of
talking about this stuff unlike email
autoresponders and all that stuff from
the first book which kind of bores me to
tears at this point the the
physiological stuff is so rewarding
because it's it's a tangible visible
result right and and and when people go
on it I mean you do get immediate
feedback and it's really really awesome
and for those for those this is
particularly true for certain
nationalities and I mean there's
obviously genetic differences but for
for a lot of women out there who might
get discouraged early on part of the
reason for the first say 10 to 14 days
that some women in particular do not see
a dramatic weight change on the scale is
because they're increasing their protein
intake and they're actually losing a lot
of visceral fat number one and number
two we're putting on muscle which is a
which is a very positive thing in almost
every case yeah and and then they start
to see the the subcutaneous fat that the
you know the fat under the skin which is
more visible in the mirror obviously
start to drop off in sort of weeks two
and three and that's why it's so
important I think for a lot of people to
to really take stock of how they feel
like you noticed the impulse sort of the
the desire to the hot the unnecessary
hunger going away to take note of those
things and instead of looking at the
scale because it's such a blunt
instrument and it can be very misleading
so I don't weigh myself at all I can see
that changes in the way that my clothes
are fitting differently I'm wearing much
more smaller sizes and I can tell in the
way that might disagree that I look and
I don't really need to see I know that
when my exercise when I'm exercising
more that it's definitely a much more
visible but and also when I'm like
delaying off and sometimes I'll get lazy
and I'll just eat like beef jerky or
something like that which is not
processes of all the stuff in it but you
know that there there's like when I when
I really take the time to make make my
own food and stuff that that's when I
can really see a huge difference
it's that when I get lazy like you know
there's like the salad dressings and
stuff like that which probably have
hidden sugar in that you know so I
I can definitely sac-fly there but not
that much either you're not eating
anything that we've been breading or
anything like that you know or like
sauces flour then that's not
see bad but it can be really you can't
you can actually have pretty luxurious
sign eating on on program not even on a
teeth day oh definitely and most people
if I go out to a meal with almost anyone
at any restaurant they never ask me
about my diet because they don't realize
that I'm even on a diet and generally
yeah it's very good and and I would say
to people out there also who are
thinking of going on any type of diet
and here's the thing even if you're not
on a diet you're on a diet
I mean diet is really in the scientific
sense just the the food that you have
actually consume so you're on a diet one
or the other but you have to rig the
game in the beginning so that you can
win right at least for the first few
weeks and so for instance I I would like
to say that I'm you know whipping up a
Food Network worthy meal every meal and
just you know slicing and dicing and
it's you know it's it's worthy of
recording for posterity but it's not I'm
lazy like everybody else and so if you
were to look at my refrigerator right
now literally I have I have single serve
guacamole and single serve black bean
hummus from I think BJ's or one of these
discount clubs I've gotten like Lifta
for chicken wrapped up in some plastic
foil and a handful of other things and
then I have a few supplements that are
on hand like glutamine and whatnot so
that I do I've done no cooking today and
I'm not hungry and that's totally okay
it's totally ok I heard there are other
there are readers who have literally I
kid you not lost you know fifty to a
hundred pounds and the only beans that
they consume and you don't have to eat a
ton of beans but the only beans they've
consumed or refried beans it doesn't
have to be fancy so in any case I am I'm
thrilled the ear that you're making
progress and obviously I'm happy to help
any time but living it let me ask you on
the meal side of things so if you had
your your last meal you know you're
you're in death row what are you gonna
go out with what's what's your last meal
I think I would
really want to have the Farfalla
with salmon and vodka you know that the
or the penne alla vodka that's my
favorite salmon and vodka a cream sauce
with the pops is so good and so that's
probably that and then maybe and some
kind of a bread thing not so many sweets
I guess maybe a little but I don't
really I don't know the sauce is a thing
but you know again it's a good employee
I so don't crave it like I used to like
I used to have to have it once a day at
least like pasta salad or you know some
kind of a breakfast pasta oh that's so
you know it's a breakfast upset but I
mean it's like so weird how I just don't
have an I don't want he not only care
you know it's really weird it's crazy
it's crazy when that yeah when that type
of shift happens do you have a favorite
curse word is there any one sort of a
curse word or insulting I got it I love
it just it rolls off the tongue this is
really this is really a keeper for me it
just like resonates one that I think I
use the most which is probably the one
that everybody uses the most I think it
is a very flexible word you know it can
it can it can take many different forms
I think that's part of why it's so
useful and negative and then it can be
romantic which is really funny romantic
thing that you can say and weird like it
should be really the most horrible thing
you could say to somebody for the best
thing to so I really love the
user-friendly quality of the word
there's a there's a wonderful little
book called English as a second [ __ ]
language and it talks about all of the
uses of the word [ __ ] because you think
about it it's actually very very
particular right because you can say
that's
that's [ __ ] incredible that's mmm but
you can't say that's incredible like you
there are ways very specific ways that
you can use it or not use it that's you
know unbelieva [ __ ] bald nod doesn't
really work right so you you really have
to you've at you've sort of developed a
fluency at a certain point is the native
English speaker with that word I find
the Australians are really fond of it
but yeah just an observation it's a
great word it's my favorite yeah good
one so if you could I want to be I know
you have a show coming up and that that
you probably want to do some prep for
that
speaking of which just a few more
questions but if you look at your best
performances in the say hour before you
go on stage what are the commonalities
like what what gets you in the zone what
what rituals or routines do you have
usually it's just a nice meal sometimes
I'll have a book sometimes they'll just
be reading backstage which is a really
nice thing to do sometimes it's very
busy you know you can never really
predict that there's no I have to
perform so much that there's no way that
I can regulate that hour before there's
always a different situation
you know the different cities or
different social situations different
social settings I'm coming from
something else so there's really no way
to gauge but I like to have you know
sometimes a bit of wine in a red wine
any any particular time any particular
type of red wine I like something like a
Shiraz or a Shiraz probably or a Malbec
something dry not sweet just something
kind of kind of that's very hard hard
key but flavorful but not like a juice
like a red like a grape juice like very
very good nice intense wine so that
that'd be nice
if you're able to read what type of book
would would you choose oh I love
biographies and so I'm reading right now
how to be a movie star which is like all
about Elizabeth Taylor I think it's
really fascinating
I love movie star biographies and the
way that Hollywood was like to people
like Liberace and Elizabeth Taylor and
you know these kinds of figures who were
very flamboyant and symbolic of a time
but led pretty tortured lives too so
that means it's really interesting so I
like that kind of stuff is it do you
know people who are at the operating at
the higher level in Hollywood who are
not tortured it just seems like it's a
tortured town in a lot of ways but are
there are there people who come to mind
who are very successful in some capacity
in Hollywood who are not tortured and if
so why are they not tortured I don't
know I think that there is a high level
of people who are tortured but then
there's also a lot of when you know a
lot of people who have done taken taken
measures to help themselves like whether
it's through sobriety or some kind of
program or even some kind of a religion
that makes things a little bit better I
do see happiness out there you know I do
see a lot of joy in regards to work but
you know sometimes the more brilliant
somebody is the more crazy they are too
so we don't really have a really good
handle on people is realize the most
well-adjusted person the nicest and
well-adjusted and famous and successful
was probably Dave Grohl from the fruit
fly service he is the most funny
individual I've ever met and so generous
and kind and really one of them
fantastic artists of all time oh it's no
incredible just phenomenal what now
happy do you think that that that why do
you think he is that way because of
course I mean he's seen some dark things
very dark things I think you know and I
think that part of it is also drummers
tend to be very positive people and I
think it is the physical activity I
think it is that high-intensity interval
training that is drumming you know
that's a great observation I never
really thought of it that way but that
that actually makes perfect sense to me
Wow interesting any day I need to I have
some hand drums I got to tell you it's
like the difference between a day of
even 10 minutes of drumming and a day of
no drumming is very very stark I mean
it's it is I think the physical movement
and using the hands for something other
than pecking at a keyboard for sure so
on that note I'll let you I'll let you
get off the phone but where can people
find more from you learning more about
you where can people check out what
you're up to
well my website is Margaret Cho calm and
that's where all my tour dates are I
have some blog blogs stuff up there I
have kind of everything photos and you
know just like kind of an overview of
what I do and then I have I'm on Twitter
at Margaret Cho and I'm on Facebook at
mother show and that's I do a bit of
Instagram it's Margaret underscore too
but yeah that sets all my stuff and I'm
very active everywhere there you know I
really enjoyed that too so you know I I
get a lot it's funny how it's much
easier life is when you can verify
people like oh you know it's like oh yes
it really is that person's like it's
like you can really see them so mixed
life much easier
yeah it certainly does and thank you so
much for making the time hopefully next
time you're in SF we can share
glass or two or three of wine i toasted
my for our body which is you know you
you will see and i think that you will
be really excited because you from my
photographs from like stuff that i've
done you can really tell the difference
and i haven't had like this photoshoot
or anything so i look forward to that so
that you can see what things have things
have done you know it's also given me a
lot make me feel a lot younger too which
is i appreciate thank you my pleasure
thank you for putting the words into
action i just write it write about your
stuff down on a couple pages but now
this it really makes my entire week and
week we can decide whether it's going to
be a cheap meal or a or
standard-compliant slow carb meal but
either way would love to would love to
join you for a bite or drink and thank
you so much for the time so i'll let you
get ready for your gig everybody check
out margaret online and i'll put a bunch
of links in the show notes as well and
until next time thank you so much for
being yourself thank you so much thank
you for supporting the sponsors this
show 99designs which is your one-stop
shop for all things graphic design
related go to 99designs comm forward
slash tim to see the projects that I've
put up including the mock-ups and drafts
of the book cover for the 4-hour body
ex-officio ex-officio and i go way back
ex-officio dot-com forward slash tim you
can see the clothing that i've used for
traveling through 20 plus countries
including the underwear by the way
that's about half of my underwear drawer
right now ex-officio comm forward slash
tim you can also see the viral video
that i put out which shows you how to
travel the world with ten pounds or less
as always you can subscribe to this
podcast on itunes and you can find all
of the links and resources from this
episode as well as every other episode
by going to 4-hour workweek comm forward
slash podcast spell it all out or you
can go to 4-hour work week calm and just
click on podcast feedback if you have
feedback I would love your thoughts
anything at all who you'd like to see on
this show ping me on Twitter at
Ferris that's twitter.com /t fer Riss or
on facebook at facebook.com forward
slash Tim Ferriss with two R's and two
S's and until next time thank you for
listening